اصعب امتحان في العالم ليس امتحان توظيف
في ناسا والامتحان لقبول في هارفارد ولحظ
اوكسفورد هذا الامتحان يدفع ببعض الراسبين
فيه للانتحار انهم امتحان قبول الجامعه في
الصين او كما يعرف بيجاكاو فلمده يومين من
كل سنه يعيش ملايين من الطلبه مع اسرهم
حاله صعبه من الضغط والرعب الكبير خلال
امتحانات قبول الجامعه وكاله شينخوا قالت
ان الامتحان يشل انشطه عده بالبلاد حيث
تغلق المباني الحكوميه والمصانع ابوابها
ويمنع السائقون من استعمال منبه سيارتهم
ومن يخالف القوانين يعاقب بغرامات كبيره
وكل ذلك حتى لا يتعكر صفو هدوء الطلاب
كاكاو سمي باصعب امتحان في العالم ليس
لصعوبه اسئلته او الحراسه المشدده فيه بل
لان وظائف الطلبه المستقبليه تحدد بهذا
الامتحان تقارير افادت بان نظام التعليم
الصيني واجه انتقادات واسعه ويرى نقاده
بانه الاس وء في العالم لانه يتسبب في
انتحار الطلبه الذين فشلوا في احراز نتائج
تؤهلهم لدخول الجامعات او دراسه تخصص لم
يعجبهم
[موسيقى]